aujourd'hui je me trouve aux assises du
numérique à port-marly c'est la seconde
édition tout au long de la journée se
dérouleront des ateliers des tables
rondes sur différents thèmes comme la
santé l'éducation ou encore la
cybersécurité mais tout d'abord pour
présenter l'événement on va aller à la
rencontre du président de seine et
yvelines numériques bertrand coquard
fait partie
seconde édition des assises du numérique
c'est important c'est un moment
important pour les villes les élus est
également nos partenaires de pouvoir se
rencontrer et présenter les différentes
options que propose sony numérique assez
à ses usagers adhérents am donc on est
sur la cybersécurité on est sur la santé
bref on est sur le numérique au sein des
collectivités plusieurs communes des
yvelines en ont été victimes ces
derniers jours aujourd'hui la
cybersécurité devient un enjeu
primordial
alors comment se prémunir d'une cyber
attaque
l'adjudant chef de la gendarmerie des
yvelines nous aide à y voir plus clair
alors c'est un peu dur parce qu on a
différents types de cyberattaques donc
le problème il est là c'est que en de
manière générale de manière générale en
fait il ya toujours des solutions qui
sont peu près on va dire qui permet
d'atteindre tous m'a déjà avoir une
gestion des mots de passe avoir
effectivement des postes qui voir à
l'identifiant et le mot de passe par
personne à voir aussi bas des mises à
jour des logiciels des mises à jour de
leur antivirus éviter de brancher
n'importe quoi sur son ordinateur donc
voilà est aussi avoir une politique de
communication et d'informer surtout
quand j'étais tout à l'heure de
formation de ses personnels parce que si
le personnel qui utilisent le réseau
informatique de collectivité n'est pas
formé bas donc il ne sait pas quoi faire
pour éviter son attaque et surtout il ne
connaît pas la réaction qui doit avoir
pour peut-être éviter de propager cette
attaque tout simplement le secrétaire de
mairie un jour a essayé de se connecter
pour faire une action sur le pc de la
commune et s'est aperçu que toutes les
données étaient cryptées donc il m'a
appelé en catastrophe pour me dire allez
vite à la mairie se passe quelque chose
et c'est parce que lui à distance
puisqu'il est à 10 km ne pouvait pas
arrêter le système je suis là pour
témoigner justement de ce qui nous est
arrivé de ce qu'on a mis en place et
puis surtout alerter les gens que il est
tout le monde est concerné quoi c'est
surtout ça papa comme moi pensaient que
naïvement ça ne peut arriver qu'à des
grosses entreprises ou des grosses
administration voilà clap de fin pour
cette seconde édition des assises du
numérique
beaucoup d'autres sujets ont été évoqués
tout au long de la journée comme la
vidéo verbalisation les outils connectés
ou encore la lutte contre les dépôts
sauvages grâce au numérique au total
quatre tables rondes 19 ateliers pour
éduquer et sensibiliser au numérique